each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
thank you all for coming my name's Simon
Mercer and you're attending the brown
bag session on the Microsoft biology
foundation so i'll be talking for about
the next 40 minutes or so i don't think
i'm going to fill the full hour slot
what i'm going to show you here is i'm
going to describe a little bit about the
background why we did a biology
foundation in the first place and the
different motivations for that then i'm
going to go on to give you some
information about the microsoft biology
foundation version 1 and then I'll
finish up by showing some demos of what
we've actually built so let me just
launched into the first part of that
essentially what we were trying to do is
we were trying to create an open source
framework of bioinformatics
functionality that could be freely
available to everyone who needed such a
framework now the purpose behind this
just to break it down we wanted it to be
open source because we want other people
to collaborate with us we want to build
it in collaboration with others and we
want other people to be able to use it
whether they're in the commercial world
or the academic world on an equal
footing we wanted to do a library
because well we thought about the
community that we were trying to address
here and essentially the way it works is
the biological community is very
fragmented there are lots of small
groups with very specific needs if we
actually created a set of applications
to serve those needs we would be on the
hook for maintain the maintenance of
hundreds or possibly thousands of
different applications which was a huge
workload for anyone on the other hand if
you give biologists a copy of Visual
Studio sit them down and tell them to go
read the manual then you're putting in
front of them an extremely high barrier
to actually creating computing
applications that are useful to them
computer science is a skill in its own
right and if you're a biologist you're
not a computer scientist necessarily
although you probably know most of what
a biologist wants to see because that's
what you practice every day we don't
necessarily know the best ways to
implement it so if we're not going to
give them a set or it will fit over that
give them visual studio and we're not
going to give them a set of finished
tools is
something that we can provide which
perhaps lowers the barrier to building
your own tools and that's the point of
this this is a library of bioinformatics
algorithms and other functions which are
exactly that we pre-written trunks of
functionality for you so you can build
the applications more quickly perhaps
it's useful to go back and think a
little bit about the motivations for why
we would do this the first thing I would
do is just showing that a complex
diagram of the genomics and proteomics
domains there are different types of
activities occurring under the broad
heading of bioinformatics and they go
all the way from examining and
assembling the DNA sequence that comes
straight out of a DNA sequencing machine
through to inferring the function of
genes determining their expression
levels the location of the gene products
within the cells and their function on
and their effect on the an organism as a
whole we're starting at the very
beginning of that pipeline and mbf the
microsoft biology foundation is
represented the placement of it is
represented by the double-headed arrow
there on the on the left of the screen
just above it you will see another arrow
ALS that's the amalga life science
product from microsoft microsoft has a
healthcare business healthcare solutions
group and their primary offering at the
moment is is amalga the hospital
information management system so if
you're dealing with patient records
large-scale clinical data then there's a
hospital information management system
you can buy if you're a hospital which
will automate that process the process
of collecting the information and
presenting it to you the clinician
that's a very big product it costs a lot
of money it's it's intended for the
enterprise and the malco life science
moves one step further down from that
and that deals with discovery
informatics data from pharmaceutical
companies it adds a semantic layer on
top of gene expression information gene
information patient information and
things like that allows people to
explore that information to aggregate it
and to reason over it to extract new
knowledge from the information related
to to drug discovery now what we wanted
to do is we considered the space that
lay immediately before that even closer
to the instrumentation which generates
the raw data we're interested in
anything that comes out with DNA
sequencing machine through two
contiguous fully annotated DNA sequence
the very earliest stages of the genomics
discovery pipeline now that's an area
where open source is very common a lot
of algorithms are developed in that area
by academics who prototype them or
generate full-fledged applications they
make them available perhaps under
licenses that prevent commercial use
sometimes they're available for
commercial use and there's a different
license for commerce versus
non-commercial use sometimes it's GPL
and and that can cause companies like us
some problems if we deal with that
sometimes they're released you know on a
web site somewhere and the 7 users
worldwide it's a it's a it's an
environment where there's a lot of
different standards everybody had like
everyone else to adopt the standard of
any of any given academic is created
there's a tremendous diversity in the
different applications that are
available they're licensed in a
tremendously broad range of ways and
they're on the cutting edge now
pharmaceutical companies when they're
doing their discovery informatics can't
ignore these things because very often
they represent the latest developments
in their field however there then
becomes a problem because they they
might have a large enterprise level
system which is supposed to manage all
of the information of their discoveries
they need to integrate it with this
rapidly changing open-source ecosystem
app of academic code now we saw an
opportunity there for mbf that can live
in that space it can provide an easy on
ramp into the larger systems which
include Microsoft systems but can be
others too but it can also consume data
from this very broad and rapidly
changing world of file formats in a
and idiosyncratic academic software that
represents the cutting edge of research
so what we represent here with the NBF
arrow is we're in the genomic space
we've already done some of this and I'll
be showing you that our progress in a
minute but we're also a little bit in
the functional genomic space dealing
with G Wasa's is listed over there which
is genome-wide Association studies
determining the relationship of genomic
polymorphisms to susceptibility to
disease sensitivity to drugs etc so
extracting knowledge from the human
genome but primarily we're rooted in
this most basic form of digital data
that comes off sequencing machines HTC's
and G's DNA sequence well we spoke to
our customers and in this particular
case our customers are academic
researchers this is a microsoft research
project it's based in external research
external researcher the same group that
are organizing this meeting and so you
understand that the job of external
research is to show academics what
Microsoft can offer in research in the
research space this happens to be
showing biologists what Microsoft can
offer so we went to the labs and we
looked at what is already in use what we
found is a lot of pearl and a lot of
Python a little bit of Visual Basic a
set of tools which are not strongly
typed are created by postdocs typically
the postdoc leaves the the tools stop
working one day nobody knows how to
maintain them so there are a lot of
problems there they create script based
pipelines there's a lot of error in
those DNA sequencing is changing very
rapidly the first generation of DNA
sequencing using a technique called
Sanger sequencing tended to produce
reads on the DNA molecule a strings of a
species and G's about six hundred to a
thousand characters in length now
there's a range of second generation
sequencing technologies which are
generating in two days and for fifty
thousand dollars or maybe even less than
that the the same amount of information
that the Human Genome Project generated
in ten years with 23 labs at the cost of
five hundred million dollars so the
world has changed in only ten years and
it's about to change again there's a new
generation of sequencing technologies
which
in terms of their data flow of dwarfing
the existing ones and then you come back
to the fact that this data is being
handled with pulse perl scripting
pipelines the two worlds are clearly
going to collide at some point and
scientists are very well aware that
they're going to have problems dealing
with this large amount of scientific
data and perhaps we can provide some
help there so we recognize there are
pain points in the academic community
around the quantity of scientific data
being generated the tribal knowledge
that are referred to on this slide
refers to this post doc problem as I
described it you get a postdoc in they
turn out not to be very good at the web
bench they see the computer in the
corner of the lab and they pick up they
start hacking out solutions on that
computer they're trained in biology now
not trained in computer science the
result is code that even though it might
extremely well mirror the needs of the
scientist is pulley architected fully
documented and very often fully
implemented as well and so when that
post doc leaves it's as if that code had
never been written somebody else has to
find find a way of fixing that problem
now if you're nih you would love to find
a way or NSF for that matter you'd love
to find a way that you're funding
dollars didn't go into re-implementing
the wheel every time a new grant came up
wouldn't it be nice if you actually
actually could rely on a set of basic
functionality that would write the first
twenty to thirty percent of every
application and you could simply just
download it rely on it because it's well
architected and well documented so you
can understand how it works well we'll
be we'll be seeing how we got on with
that in a minute our target scenarios
when we were designing this and building
this well we're trying to make make it
easier for scientists to get what they
need more rapidly these early stages of
the DNA sequencing pipeline have been
have been performed for two decades now
so really it's not rocket science
anymore it's not really in the domain of
scientific research anymore it's become
commoditized and you should be able to
rely on certain standard steps that will
extract the majority of the correct
information from the data it's the data
no longer costs that much because you
know fifty thousand run fifty thousand
dollars for a whole human genome is
relatively cheap I believe now you can
actually find whole claim
the whole human genome can be done for
under ten thousand dollars and the
thousand-dollar genome is expected to
happen in 23 years so with prices
collapsing at that rate you can get 3
billion base pairs of human DNA for a
thousand dollars all of a sudden if you
find some problem there you need to
reanalyze the data you need to keep all
a huge hard disk somewhere with all of
the basic data on it you just take
another drop of blood from the same
patient sequence it again it's just not
going to be that expensive so rapid
application development is valuable for
scientists because it means that more
time is spent actually using the
applications that can extract new
knowledge from the data rather than
building the applications we also want
to ensure that we can do things like
cross-species comparisons we went down
to the University of Washington just
local here in Seattle and we we talked
to a group of genomics experts they're
led by Evan eichler and his lab they
happen to be working on exactly the
scenario of comparing different
sequenced different genomes from
different species looking at their
similarities and their differences and
so we were very interested in learning
about that so that we could provide the
tools that would enable them to do their
science more rapidly and build them into
the Microsoft biology foundation so
comparative genomics is an area that
interests us very much from in terms of
it's just been one where we've been able
to get a lot of information we're also
interested in single nucleotide
polymorphism identification this is a
change of an atc orgy in the in the in
the genome single nucleotide
polymorphisms are one of the major
contributors to why we don't all look
the same and respond the same to drugs
they're responsible for a lot of the
variation between individuals if you
understand patterns of single-nucleotide
polymorphisms which ones who inherit
from your mother or your father then you
might be able to understand or you can
gain some insight certainly into
sensitivity to drugs inherited diseases
etc and so being able to identify those
polymorphisms in a strand of DNA becomes
very valuable and then being able to
identify which sets of polymorphism is
called haplotype
travel around together for an earlier
and our inherited separately so we've
been working on haplotype in as well so
what do we offer people well I think
I've spoken about most of this
essentially the programmers that are
providing a service to those scientists
get more of their self pre-written they
can build their applications more
rapidly what we've done is we've also
been able to demonstrate the value of
other Microsoft technologies by
integrating them into the Microsoft
biology foundation i'll be showing you
some examples of that later if you're a
developer there's no price better than
free if you can get all of this just
because you can go to a site and
download it and you can use it whether
your commercial or academic and you can
then license any subsequent application
that you generate using these libraries
under any terms well that's very nice
it's also adaptable because if you can
then contribute your coat back to that
library then other people can benefit
not only from the initial library but
from the advances that you've managed to
make to their to that library for the
biologists they see their research move
more rapidly they see more more results
for less time and for less money and we
can also show that the some benefit
using the desktop in genomics research a
pattern that we found time and again is
that biologists will you know surf the
web using Internet Explorer they will
read their email using outlook they will
present their slides like this using
PowerPoint they'll write their papers
using word and then when it comes to the
real science they'll go on to their
linux cluster and and run their
applications well you know in terms of
processing power the desktop is a
tremendous machine these days you know
mine has four cores it runs hurting I
don't know three gig gigahertz they're
about it's got gigabytes if not
terabytes of disk space so you know it's
a machine that's easily capable of doing
science and so why not build
applications that you can access on the
desktop straight away doesn't mean
they've got to throw the other
applications away but if you're sitting
doing nothing but browse the web on a
machine with four cause you're wasting a
lot of processing power and why not use
it as well as that a lot of the
instrumentation that we're talking about
DNA sequencing machines
they come with pcs attached and then
there's usually an effort by the
informatics groups to move the data off
those pcs onto the Linux clusters for
further analysis why not do the analysis
closer to the machine so we also of
course being Microsoft we're interested
in seeing whether other groups can learn
from what we're doing here and so there
are there is a potential if we had a
Microsoft biology foundation for
transferring this into other groups now
that doesn't mean that this code is
going to become a part of a product well
what it does mean is we can exercise
other pieces of the Microsoft product
suite if you like by applying mbf to
those areas one of them is the amalga
life science product which I've already
talked about we can provide a smooth
on-ramp for people scaling up from small
work in single labs all the way to the
big enterprise level that amount of life
science deals with the high performance
computing folks have actually been
spending a lot of time talking to open
source while groups that have been
producing academic applications and
releasing them under open-source
licenses around the bioinformatics and
genomic space and they've been
persuading them to include build targets
for the HPC cluster among their other
offerings they've been very successful
with that now if they then expose those
services those applications through web
services we could link to those and
build a set of hpc applications we're
also interested in finding out where the
NBF can run effectively on on a cluster
as well and then there's as you of
course everybody's talking about the
cloud just like everybody was talking
about the grid just like everybody's
talking about clusters but now it's the
cloud the cloud gives us the possibility
with very large numbers huge numbers of
commodity machines that you can scale up
workloads so long as you have a highly
parallel application that you want to
that you want to use and so we're
looking at ways of building services in
the cloud that can be accessed from the
desktop and using those and producing
these as prototypes so that other people
can go there either you know take that
credit card create an azure account load
the service into that account and run
their own service or they can take a
look at the code and
understand how to build as your
applications for as your services I
should say so that's why we did what we
did and this is what we did it's my
pleasure to announce that on Friday last
week we released version 1 of the
Microsoft biology foundation it's been a
long road and I'm very much like to
thank the other people in my group for
for doing this especially Mike sis
Kowski and Bob Davidson but there are
many others that were involved version 1
because this is an open source project
version 1 is effectively just a snapshot
of the source tree it's a
well-documented and heavily tested a
snapshot of the of the source tree it's
a snapshot that was taken once we'd got
all of the features that we decided
needed to be in version one actually
implemented but work is continuing we've
started on version two already in many
ways and you can go and you can take a
look at our work because it's all on
codeplex and i'll be talking about how
you can do that in a minute so what do
we actually do well we did exactly what
we said we were going to do we built a
set of dot net of net implemented
functionality were relevant to
bioinformaticians so uh net for so we
can leverage the the latest features of
net it's released under the MS PL open
source license similar to a bsd license
it's available for commercial and
academic use free of charge I should add
a little legal disclaimer it's a please
read the license if I'm not giving you a
particularly accurate view it's only six
lines long or something it's not a
problem chat OSI approved license so
we're truly open source its foundation
on which other tools can be built so it
does indeed do that abstracts out the
bottom twenty percent of everything you
need to do if you want to implement new
bioinformatics applications and it
provides a set of components and what it
provides is setup file pauses and for
matters so you can read files you can
round trip between one file formats and
another it supports DNA RNA and protein
sequences their assembly in a
manipulation and their alignment to
discover evolutionary similarities and
differences between species I have an
example of that I'll show you in a
minute it provides a framework for
algorithms now primarily what we're
doing at the moment is we're
implementing standard
genomics algorithms around alignment and
Assembly of the DNA sequences the reason
why standard algorithms is there's no
secret source here what we've done is
we've done the implementation we've
included the the reference the
literature reference to the paper that
describes their algorithm actually in
the code so you can see it and we've
made sure that it's consummately well
documented so that if you want to use
this as a teaching tool show other
people how to construct applications
using c sharp and net it's there for you
and you've got a link straight to the
literature so you know exactly how it's
supposed to work we've also provided a
web connector framework Microsoft
doesn't want to become NCBI the National
Center for Biotechnology information
ncbi is doing an excellent job storing
large databases of all the DNA that gets
sequenced in the world we we're not
going to curate that and maintain it as
effectively as they are it's their job
they're the community accepted standard
along with the DNA data bank of japan
and the european bioinformatics
institute those three institutions
around the world are the canonical
repository for DNA sequence information
and they expose a service called blast
the basic local alignment search tour
they run that very efficiently on a
cluster they expose it as a web service
and we consume that web service so we
can actually access that directly from
the desktop without going to their
website and we've done that as part of
an extendable framework of a web web
service connectors so that if we're not
connecting to your favorite web service
that's no problem or all you've got to
do is look how we implemented blast and
you can add your own web service
alongside it or if we don't par as a
file format that's your favorite file
format again that's no problem made it
very easy to build more passes as a
plug-in model and add them to the basic
set that we support in mdf now because
this is community curated and i'm kind
of jumping forward a couple of slides
i'll probably get to it in more detail
in a minute but this is community
curated what that means is that if you
want to develop new pieces and
contribute them back to thee to the NBF
framework will incorporate them into
that framework and we will release it
again as open source so over time the
snow ball rolls downhill and
gathers momentum and gathers size and
mbf might start as a relatively small
set of functionality but it can be
extended by the community in the
directions the community most cares
about to benefit scientists the most so
what is it intended to do well I talked
about this I'm not really going to spend
much time on it it's primarily focused
on genomics in other words it deals with
everything that comes out with DNA
sequencing machine through two
contiguous for the annotated sequence we
don't cover all of that space yet but
we've just finished version one and
we're moving on to version two and we'll
be filling in some of the gaps as we go
it's important to say at this point that
we try not to implement features that we
think of good ideas what we try and do
is we implement features that the
scientists tell us a good ideas we don't
have a good use case founded on real
scientists who are going to use it we
don't implement it whatever it might be
it's yeah we have finite amount of time
we want to make sure that the features
that we use are actually getting the
features that we build are actually
getting used there are other biology
frameworks out there there's bio Java
bioperl biopython by a ruby etc we were
going to call this bionet but for
various legal reasons that name has been
taken by this so we can't do that so the
Microsoft biology foundation it is we
believe that we offer a reasonable
alternative to these other frameworks
these other frameworks tend to have
suffered in some ways because they've
been around for 10 years on the on the
one well 10 or 20 years in some cases on
the one hand that means they have a
hugely greater range of functionality
than we have if you if you download them
today on the other hand they've grown
organically for 10 or 20 years and I've
spoken to many of the maintainer of
these libraries and in some cases they
really wish they had the opportunity to
start from scratch we're coming into the
genomic space much later version 2 DNA
sequencing is now available version
third generation is coming soon many of
the initial problems have been solved
many of the very broad range of file
formats that are supported by these
other libraries have subsequently fallen
out of favor with the community the
people tend to have separate to settle
down fast q Sam BAM and a few other
formats and we support that relatively
narrow range of formats although as I
say its extensive
so we've learned to a certain extent
from their example as they've they've
forged ahead in the in the
bioinformatics field ahead of us there
are also some unique example or some
unique benefits from using Microsoft
platform here we have a very powerful
set of visualization tools and over the
summer we have some interns who are
experimenting with using pivot and sea
dragon and deep zoom to visualize
genomic data we hope to see the results
of that soon guys and yes and we also we
also have things like dotnet parallel
extensions which is a net for
development what that does is it
automatically senses the number of
processors and cause on the machine on
which mbf is being run and it will
parallel eyes out an algorithm to take
advantage of the full power of that
machine that means that what we've done
is some of the algorithms that we've
implemented and not the absolute
standards that I described earlier
they're parallelized versions so they
take advantage of the machine on which
they wrote yes large data sets we try
and deal with large data sets
effectively we largely succeed it's
worth mentioning a few things about the
design goals of what we did here what
we've tried to do is we tried to make it
extensible as I say we don't implement
everything and so we so what we do is we
provided a plug-in architecture so that
you have a set of AP is that you can
code against which make it very easy to
extend this in new directions this is
good because then we'll accept the
contributions if you do extend it in new
directions and we'll bake it into the
next version of mdf and release it as
open source its language neutral because
it's built on top of mbf it supports all
languages the common language runtime
supports which last count was around
about 70 so if your programming style is
visual basic that's fine you can you can
contribute in visual basic if you prefer
Python or a functional language like F
sharp then those are also available to
you so you can develop on this in a way
which which results in all languages
being equally compatible and you can
develop applications or make
contributions to the core libraries
whatever language most suits your
programming style and the the nature of
the problem you have to solve because
we're built on top of net we can also be
assured that we're in the mainstream of
Microsoft technologies what that means
is you know wherever as you goes next
you can be pretty sure that net
assemblies will just work out of the box
if you're interested in implement sequel
server has its own CLR within it and you
can add some code you can decorate some
of the classes in mbf and it'll actually
run inside or some of the classes will
run inside the CLR so you can actually
integrate mbf with your with your
database and there's a range of other
things as well that you can do in that
space interoperability well it's not
really true this last statement on the
slide if I'd noticed it when I was
looking through the slides earlier I
probably would have edited it out but it
does give me a segue into what we're
trying to do here we're very much aware
that science isn't a Microsoft
monoculture that there's a very wide
range of other platforms being used
principally linux OS tone etc in science
if we're going to be useful and that's
our goal here is to be useful to
scientists we have to be interoperable
and so what we're doing is we're
evaluating mbf to see how it would work
with mono project open source
implementation of the net to see whether
we can be cross platform also anything
that exposes itself through web services
we can consume because of our web
service framework and so what we're
trying to do is we're trying to
deliberately build this in a way which
can access other tools on other
platforms in terms of non Microsoft
tools on the Microsoft platform that's
also possible because as I say we have a
plug-in model and so if you when we
extend we haven't currently said we
don't currently have supported databases
but you can bet that when we build that
part of MDF will support sequel server
and we'll do it very well but if you
have an Oracle database well it's a
plug-in model so if you want to write a
plug-in that accesses your my sequel
database or your Oracle database I would
invite you to do it and contribute that
plug-in back to the project and we were
we will release it as open source
alongside the
of mbf because we do accept that you
know people should use Microsoft because
it's useful not because you feel locked
in so what do we actually have well it's
pretty straightforward this little
diagram it's not a comprehensive
architecture but it gives you some
flavor of what we're talking about here
it's a set of it's a set of four things
one is an internal object model that
models the biological objects we've been
talking about here like proteins and
peptides and DNA sequences and RNA
sequences and the different encodings
for those things we have a set of file
passes and writers we have a set of
algorithms and we have a set of web
service connectors that's all that NBF
is but and it's important to point this
out because I could stand up here and
page through code all day and show you a
library but it's not very exciting to
look at so we built some applications
that demonstrate that functionality and
that's what i'll be showing you in a
minute but mbf itself is not an
application it's a foundation and you
can build your applications more rapidly
with it is an example well I'm going to
show you a demo anyway so I'll skip that
one I'll skip that one too so how do you
get NBF well we launched this web page
research microsoft com / x 0 that is a
link into the sort of work that we're
doing in this space now you will notice
that it says microsoft biology
foundation at the top of this page if
you go to the slash bio link it will
take you to the microsoft biology
initiative page which is slightly
different the microsoft biology
initiative is a slightly broader effort
than just the foundation and the way it
breaks down basically is that Microsoft
biology initiative consists of two sides
one side is the Microsoft biology
foundation that's the set of code I'm
talking about today the basics
implemented well we hope that are
available as chunks of functionality
that you can incorporate into your
application but on the other on the
other side we have Microsoft biology
tools there are a set of tools that
Microsoft is Microsoft Research is
produced over the years that are
directly relevant to biological research
some of these are actually built on top
of the Microsoft biology foundation and
in time we expect a greater and greater
number of those
tools will actually be built using the
Microsoft biology foundation because mbf
has been adopted as being used by our
researchers actually in in Microsoft
Research now so we have these two sides
you've got the net assemblies of the
foundation and you've got the full
fledged applications of the tools side
and collectively I for the Microsoft
biology initiative so you can download
it all from our website just down it's
licensed under ms PL it's very easy to
install we've we've taken some time to
create installers they detect
dependencies if you don't have dot net
for they'll point you to the right
location to load those we have other
tools available there and i'll be
talking about those in a minute the
documentation is all there I can kind of
skip that the source code however
doesn't live on research microsoft com
it lives in codeplex codeplex is you're
probably aware as a sourceforge that's
run by microsoft and it we found that it
hasn't been the world's easiest
sourceforge to use to be perfectly
honest but what we what we are doing is
we do our development using team
foundation server we do it in the open
on codeplex so you can go to this site
you can browse the code through the site
you can download is download the sources
a zip file you can participate in the
conversations we have with other
researchers and developers around the
world who are helping us develop
microsoft biology foundation or who are
contributing code to it and you can also
apply through that site to become
contributors yourselves if you're
interested in adding anything to it so
that's all on on codeplex as i say we've
adopted the open source and open source
strategy book we've actually been
blazing trails inside Microsoft in this
space we're not the first open source
project from Microsoft far from it but
we are a unusual project in the we're
community curated we encourage
contributions from the community and the
communities of course not necessarily
entirely created of Microsoft employees
which means our legal department has
fits from time to time because we're
bringing in code from the outside that
Microsoft does not own that's okay
because it's going out it's open source
but nonetheless it's an interesting
little journey we've been on codeplex
doesn't really support this very
well they support single branch
development and we'd like to branch they
don't support the full range of TFS and
we'd like to use far more features in
the team foundation server than are
exposed through codeplex one of the
biggest problems we have is when third
parties do contribute code to us we want
to be able to hold it and review it and
check it for quality and make sure it
complies with with the standards of the
rest of em BF prior to integrating it
and that's not really very well
supported on codeplex so we're looking
for other source forges and we're also
considering alongside a move in terms of
the sourceforge that we use we're also
thinking of perhaps a new home for the
microsoft biology foundation and so i
might be back here next year just
talking about the biology foundation
because it was not located in Microsoft
for various legal reasons we can't
actually label it a microsoft thing if
we do move to another foundation it'll
remain open source and we'll make sure
that foundation still supports all of
the ideals of the project that we've
created this should be free for
scientists and commercial users alike
we're looking at the apache foundation
among others essentially it will provide
us with a legal umbrella that separates
this a little bit from Microsoft because
as we get more contributions from the
community or though Microsoft will stay
engaged when lo longer the only the only
game in town our licensing is also
proved a little interesting Microsoft is
of course a company that sells products
and if we're trying to do open source as
well then really if open source is to be
useful in the context of the commercial
world we actually have to be able to
release some things and control it and
other things far more openly and do so
under different licenses and this is
what we found again it's caused us a few
its causes to blaze some new trails
legally as well inside Microsoft or
certainly in terms of policy inside
Microsoft the Microsoft biology
foundation MSP L completely open source
the sequence assembler which i'll be
showing you which is one of the demo
applications is also ms PL windows
presentation foundation dotnet those
sort of things it's we built it
ourselves but when we actually show you
an Excel ribbon which integrates a lot
of this by one format
functionality directly into excel
microsoft has patents and intellectual
property that it doesn't want to open up
to the rest of the world by making that
open source so what we had to do is use
another license which does allow you to
get the source code but it's not OSI
approved open source and that's the MS
LPL license what that does is it allows
you to look at this stuff implement it
any way you like but it has to be on the
Windows platform when you finished
implementing it and you so we we've had
to kind of trade off some of the pure
open-source ideals for the the realities
of working in a in a for-profit company
the show runtime is an advanced math
library that that we've also made
available it's available for download
you can read about it on online it was
made available to us so close to release
that it's not fully documented but it
actually provides a wrapper for the
Intel math kernal library and we will be
using the advanced math functionality
that makes available in a subsequent
generation of demo applications that are
based around david hackman's work on on
HIV and vaccine design so and we've
released and or a custom license because
oddly enough Intel doesn't want us to
make all the best stuff open source and
they be of I'm just going to move on
talk about the community as I say we've
we no longer think of this as a
Microsoft only effort it was conceived
to move outside of Microsoft and get a
life of its own although we will stay
engaged with that project as it moves on
in consequence we've set up a Technology
Advisory Board there's nine people on
this list and they come from three of
them are from the academic world three
of them of them from the commercial
world and all of the organizations they
represent have now adopted and our
building actively on mbf and I'll
contributing code back to us and are
using mbf in applications both in-house
and in products in some cases and as you
can see Johnson & Johnson pharmaceutical
research and development is one such
group alumina corporation with the
foremost manufacturer of DNA sequencing
machines is another one university of
washington and internally within our own
Microsoft Research II science group
david hackman steamer metal we're trying
to find ways of being faster in terms of
taking in external contributions frankly
that took a backseat while we were push
her to get version one out but now
version one is in place we're starting
to look again at better ways of bringing
in stuff quality controlling it and
getting integrated quickly because we're
also finding that when I give talks like
this and there are Microsoft ease in the
audience you'd be surprised in a company
well he probably wouldn't be surprised
company of 90,000 people there are
people out there who were biologists in
previous lives and they're only too
delighted that they get an opportunity
to fall back and work on their hobbies
in their spare time and contribute to a
microsoft project along the way so we
actually have a range of people somebody
actually implemented an entire suite of
phylogenetics algorithms over a long
weekend and where we haven't got that
incorporated yet but we've actually
sparked a lot of interest inside
Microsoft that has nothing to do with
product just a bunch of geeks playing
with biology so the bottom line we're
open source we're community developed
please come take a look at the website
contribute code if you find it
interesting if you don't find it
interesting it doesn't matter download
the code and use it for whatever you
like if it's useful to you we're going
to do periodic releases so there will be
a version too but over time what we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
transitioning progressively more into
the community the technical technical
advisory board I just showed you owns
the version one release in effect and
they'll become more involved in
promoting it in the community and being
visible ownership as we move outside of
Microsoft with this project now for as
long as there's a external research team
and for as long as that external
research team has a health care interest
will be doing projects in software that
involve biology so we'll be using mbf
and will become active contributors to
it alongside everyone else that doesn't
necessarily mean that will steer its
direction in the future because the
commercial world and the academic world
will both implement their own features
and request features from us and we'll
be implementing them alongside their our
commercial and academic partners so I'm
going to show you a couple of demos I've
told you a lot about what it is now i'm
going to show you it
reality okay so one of the things that
we've done is we've created a DNA
sequence assembly tool and I'll just
I'll just show you what that really
means I'll choose some short read DNA
sequence information and I'll launch the
assembler this is a windows presentation
foundation application it was created
for a created by us and it's essentially
only exists for one reason and that's to
show off what mbf functionality is so
don't forget we're talking about library
here we've exposed the selection of the
functionality in here to show you how
you could build your own applications oh
this is open source too so if this looks
useful to you you can download it hack
it around and your users can use it to
what you're seeing here is a set of
short reads which are small fragments of
an original DNA molecule the DNA
sequencing process takes the original
molecule shatters it randomly into
pieces and then those fragments get
reassembled and of course then what you
have is the the problem of taking all of
these fragments are overlapping them
appropriately and reconstructing the
original DNA molecule now different
sequencing technologies will produce you
fragments of different lengths sometimes
there are some additional wrinkles and
interesting bits of information like you
know you have a piece of DNA this long
and you've got you've read a bit of
information from that end and a bit of
information from that end you don't know
what's in the middle so there's all
sorts of variations it's actually quite
an interesting field here's some short
read information these reads tend to be
about 35 base pairs long which is the
HTS season GS that make up the alphabet
of DNA so what I can do is I can
assemble them together and I'm going to
choose an algorithm from this drop-down
these are different ones that we've
implemented I'm going to choose the
Swift Waterman algorithm which is a
standard algorithm it's been around for
25 or 30 years now that will assemble
those fragments find those overlaps and
reconstruct the original DNA sequence
that was a lot faster than I thought
it's normally about 15 seconds never
like okay well I'm pleased it worked so
this is a trivial amount of data because
I didn't think you'd appreciate sitting
there 10 minutes to watch me do some
more serious piece of data but as you
can see we've created a contig or
contiguous piece of DNA now what you're
seeing here in the upper window
green lines that are under this gray
area here so these green lines here
these are the original fragments as they
are aligned they con that they
collectively contribute to this blue
line at the top which is the consensus
or the reconstructed DNA molecule now if
you look in this lower window which as
you can see Scrolls as i move the upon
you can see the actual HTC's and GS from
these different fragments and you can
quite clearly see they're aligned the
reason why they're colored this way is
so that by I you can actually spot
errors or polymorphisms in those in
these DNA fragments so as you can see
that goes together pretty quickly I can
look at the report and I can see that
that took a grand total of point 44 of a
second which was pretty fast now if it
hadn't taken such a short time I could
have pulled up the which he'd crawl out
thing the the task manager and I could
have actually seen that it parallelized
out the execution across all the
although cause in this particular
machine there's only it's a two core
laptop it's kind of old actually so that
gives you a brief idea of what that as a
sequence assembler will do but I can
show you another example here which
might be a little more complex what we
have here is a set of fragments of a
prion protein from human the prion
protein is it's a it's a naturally
occurring protein that's expressed in
human brain tissue but what happens for
some mysterious reason which I don't
think anyone really understands at the
moment is it can fold in two different
ways there's a normal form a normal
conformation which is normal and leaves
you normal which is great and then
there's a second confirmation which
which results in clustering and clumps
are actually in the brain cells causes
death of the brain cells and you can get
crota valve yakov disease which is a
brain disease which will definitely kill
you there's also mad cow disease the
bovine spongiform encephalopathy which
is another version of this exact same
thing what seems to be the case is that
when you're exposed to a protein
molecule that's been folded in this
incorrect manner it catalyzes the other
protein molecules in your brain to fold
in that incorrect
manner and so although this isn't a an
organism this protein isn't it is an
infective agent this makes prion
diseases particularly dangerous because
you can actually take infected meat and
reduce it to ash and the ash is still
infective so it's an interesting
biological conundrum if you like so
again I can assemble it using
smith-waterman if I want to and I'll do
so just because although this this is
longer reads these are 700 bases long so
they is going to take a bit longer
probably take about 20 seconds this time
for sure these fragments are now being
assembled it'sit's determining the
overlaps and it's it's orienting them
and creating a contact once it's
completed I'll show you and you'll see
in a moment when it does complete that
these fragments go together perfectly
and it pretty reconstructs the original
sequence of this fragment of the prion
protein but there are different there's
a trade-off here this is kind of slow
and certainly if you're standing up here
it seems even more slow than it does of
you sitting down there but they're there
we are it's done and I can scroll
through this and I can take a look at
that assembly and I can look at
different regions of it like this i
believe there is actually no there isn't
a polymorphism i can easily find but
this data that does have a certain
amount of error introduced into it to
demonstrate that it will actually
reassemble data that's in error but as
you can see everything's gone together I
can look over here and in this tree I
can see contact one there's only a
single contech here so all of those
fragments assembled together to form a
single contiguous piece of DNA now what
i can do is i can take a look at the
report and i can see that that took
thirty point five seconds to execute so
what I could do is I could go back to
the DNA sequences here and I could run
an assembly again a second assembler and
this time I'm going to choose padena
which is just available here now padena
is padena sounds for parallel de novo
assembler and it is something that we've
implemented as part of this let me just
run it now i'll talk about it once it's
run okay so i hit that button there now
what padena does and you will notice
that was nothing like 30 point 4 seconds
by the way
budino is a DeBruyn graph-based sequence
assembler so what it does is it takes
each one of those sequences it breaks it
into small pieces actually it moves a
window across the sequence it extracts
all of the different what they call
k-mers the the short sequences that are
represented there and it creates a graph
that where adjacent nodes are separated
by only one base as you move along then
if you get repeats you'll get cycles in
your graph if you get if you've got
errors you get bubbles where two parts
in the graph dive divergent and return
you take each one of these sequences you
do that with it and then there are very
set of error correction things you do to
burst those bubbles and break the
branches in the graph and the result is
you end up with these this overlapping
array here but if you look over in this
side you've got to contact to context
one of them on the consists of a single
sequence the other one consists of all
the others so one of those sequences
didn't go in yet we know it's good data
the smith-waterman algorithm I just ran
showed you it all fits together
perfectly and so what you can see here
is that this is another algorithm you
get huge trade off in terms of speed but
unfortunately it doesn't it's it's a
little bit error prone this point out
one thing about all of em BF really
which is that if you need to know what
you're doing to do these algorithms very
easy to end up with garbage on the
screen it really honestly isn't our
fault that's how the algorithms do work
so you have to understand the data that
you're using have to understand why you
chose that algorithm you have to
understand the parameters that go into
that algorithm so this isn't for the
general public if you like this is for
people who do understand the biology but
we've implemented these algorithms these
are you know man months of work and you
can take them for free and incidentally
this algorithm the the padena one it's
very well documented and you can
actually pull it apart ricci change of
the sequencing of the the different
steps that are involved it's a six-step
algorithm you can even subclass some of
those and roll your own steps so you can
create your own custom DeBruyn graph
assembler if that's what you want to do
now if I wanted to I could take the the
reconstructed DNA molecule here and I
could run it through a web server
soon as you can see I've got a little
drop down here to select web services so
what i can do is i can click on this and
i can select one of the basic local
alignment search tools now these two are
two of those three centers around the
world that i was talking about earlier
the ebi and ncbi that offer you know all
the DNA in the world that you can go
compare that DNA sequence with and see
what it was similar to however the top
one here is different this is the bio
HPC project and I see yarik and bobbin
in the corner there so from Cornell
University thank you very much and what
Yara Kim and his team have done at the
CBS you is they ported a range of
bioinformatics applications to an hpc
cluster and they make all of that port
available to you as open source and all
exposed as web services so what we've
done is we've got an example here of
connecting to their blast web service
but there's another 126 applications at
least 43 they've been busy some
population genetics algorithm is some
DNA DNA assembly algorithms and other
things that are available free of charge
from from Cornell or you can take the
code and you can put it on your own HPC
cluster and you cannot stand up a
service that offers similar sort of hpc
in bioinformatics from your own site so
i could click on that and run it but
ncbi is up about seventy percent of the
time and it's slow so here's one I
prepared earlier and the finest
tradition of TV chefs oh yes it has
finished good okay so what this is is
it's a set of windows you can open them
and close them obviously so the
sequences that were the input or in that
pain the contig the assembly that we
produces in this pain here and then down
here we took the reconstructed molecule
and this is the result of the the web
results so you can see a set of
sequences here now what these are is
they're actually they're sortable and
groupable and you first of all and all
sorts of things but what we've done here
is we've gone to the National Center for
Biotechnology information
we've queried this reconstructed DNA
sequence against every other fragment of
DNA that they have in their database and
their database is a huge after a couple
of minutes they only return those that
match that original sequence within
certain specified parameters match you
then have a set of sequences that have
been returned to you that are very
similar to the thing you've just
sequenced and assembled so you might so
you can then look at the annotations of
those things and figure out whether you
know maybe somebody else figured out the
purpose of this molecule you've just
sequence maybe somebody else in the
world figured out a sequence the same
thing in horses and chimpanzees and fish
and and fruit flies and if they did you
can construct an evolutionary tree that
shows how this gene is evolved over time
those sort of things and you can do that
that with these sort of blast results
you can also visualize them and for this
I have to thank my steamed friend here
from from Queensland University of
Technology and I wish I picked a better
data set for you because it's not
showing this so well but I can zoom in
here this is a visualization of the data
now I'm sorry it's not the most exciting
visualization because basically what
you're seeing is big blue ring this
black cloud and because the names are
overlapping so closely over of the blue
dots that you can't really see what they
are but I can zoom in and eventually the
dots resolve but I can't seem quite far
enough to do it and each one of these
dots what it is is you see there's a
ring around a central blue dot what this
is done is it's represented all of those
blasts hit spatially so the dot in the
center is the query sequence that we
sent off to ncbi and the dots that
surround it which should really be in
more of a cloud represent all of the
other sequences DNA sequences that were
returned by that query the distance from
that central dot is proportional to the
degree of similarity between the query
sequence and the and the other sequences
that were returned and I can find out
more about each one of these individual
query sequences I can pop this window
open and pin it and I can click on one
of these oops I should probably have the
hit detail that one up right I can click
on these
and nothing appears I got it I got it
right good good and as you can see this
is from Al Caesar Caesar SEI which is
that well known species of something and
and this is a prion protein sequence
from that species PR MP tells you it's a
prion protein and I can click over here
yeah don't know what that is either one
of these days I would probably random
chance I would hit eventually an
organism I recognized but nonetheless
that's a set of those so I'm being
gesture that from the back of the room
so i think i have to end it there but
please come and see me later if you'd
like to see more demos there's plenty of
other things i could show you i can show
you multiple sequence alignments in DNA
and proteins which actually highlight
these evolutionary relationships i can
show you this same functionality
encapsulated in a in a ribbon at the top
of XL so you can do exactly everything
you've seen me do here but in an Excel
spreadsheet and biologists really like
that because they very often load data
into Excel to take a look at it anyway I
can show you the same stuff and
capsulated is individual units of
functionality and strung together as
workflows and available in trident if
you've seen our workflow engine called
Trident which is a scientific workflow
engine because it captures a lot of
provenance so you can actually do
reproduce for science and build work
scientific workflows in trident so we
have all of those things ready to go but
it's a dotnet assembly so I urge you to
experiment join the community and and
see where it takes you thank you very
much